in 2013's this is the end they amped up
the runchy humor and got wild with a lot
of their Pals including actors like
Danny McBride and chaining Tatum Emma
Watson also cameoed in the film but
there was one scene that proved to be
too much for her so she Departed the set
according to an extra who spoke to pop
focal Watson wasn't a big fan of a scene
in which Tatum was dressed in only a
leather thong The Source explained
during the scene Channing decided to do
some of his break dancing in front of
but alas he was in nothing but a thong
so Emma storms off set reportedly Watson
also wasn't impressed that Tatum had
been drinking before filming the scene
Rogan was asked about the incident in a
later interview with GQ the actor
confirmed that it did happened but
stressed that there was no bad Vibe
between them and Watson even promoted
the movie whether or not that bad blood
is really there it seems unlikely we'll
ever see the two share a screen again